bonsoir et bienvenue dans le livre de
politique votre rendez-vous politique du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec TV 78 et pour cet
épisode 234 nous sommes au Sénat mon
invité et ce soir la sénatrice des
Yvelines Martha de Sidrac
[Musique]
politique
Martha de ce DRAC bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous ce soir dans l'herbe de
politique vous êtes sénatrice LR des
Yvelines depuis 2017 et conseillère
municipal de Saint-Germain en Laye
depuis 2008 la grosse actualité
politique de ce début d'année c'est
évidemment cette réforme des retraites
au moment où nous enregistrons cette
émission le texte est débattu à
l'Assemblée nationale et les
manifestations se poursuivent toujours
en France le débat a débuté dans
l'hémicycle dans une ambiance très
tendue les députés de laupes empêchant
le ministre du Travail Olivier du soft
de prendre la parole depuis le Sénat
comment est-ce que vous avez vu cette
scène qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé
alors déjà depuis le Sénat nous nous
suivons de près vous vous en doutez bien
cette réforme qui aujourd'hui examinée à
l'Assemblée et je pense tout d'abord au
préalable il faut rappeler ce qu'est le
Parlement le Parlement c'est
l'expression de du peuple l'Assemblée
nationale les citoyens le Sénat les
collectivités territoriales et il me
semble que tout débat doit se passer
dans de sérénité la plus recherchée qui
soit et à ce titre là je trouve que
c'est un tout petit peu dommage parce
que en réalité le fond du de la réforme
le fond des débats qui pourraient être
serein sur un certain nombre de sujets
malgré les désaccords que j'entends que
tout le monde entend que l'on voit vous
avez évoqué les manifestations dans la
rue il me semble que le lieu de
l'Assemblée doit rester un lieu de débat
serein sans invective pour que chacun
effectivement puisse exprimer pleinement
ces opinions ses convictions parce que
c'est au bénéfice de nous tous c'est je
dirais ce qui fait la grandeur d'une
démocratie alors on le rappelle cette
réforme des retraites a pour but de
reporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite de deux années aujourd'hui pour
une majorité de Français cet âge et de
62 ans avec la réforme donc les Français
nés à partir de septembre 1961 partiront
3 mois plus tard à la retraite il y aura
ensuite une augmentation progressive
pour atteindre en 2030 l'âge de 64 ans
le nombre d'années de cotisations pour
obtenir une retraite raite à taux plein
passera lui aussi donc de 42 à 43 ans
alors une question revient dans le débat
très souvent c'est est-ce que cette
réforme est juste
je ne sais pas si elle est juste c'est
difficile de répondre simplement par un
OUI ou par un nom en revanche chez les
nécessaires et je crois que ce débat là
aurait dû même avoir lu beaucoup plus
tôt il se trouve que au dernier
quinquennat le travail n'a pas été fait
le débat n'a pas pu se mener là on
l'aborde on l'aborde peut-être même pas
suffisamment
sur le fond en tant que tel mais il est
nécessaire ce débat est nécessaire et je
crois que c'est très fort ma j'ose le
dire est nécessaire également alors si
on regarde un petit peu chez nos voisins
et qu'on sort un peu du spectre français
là je de départ en Allemagne est
aujourd'hui de 65 ans et 10 mois il
passera progressivement à 67 ans en 2031
en Espagne c'est 65 ans avec au moins
37,5 années de cotisation en Italie
c'est même 67 ans au Royaume-Uni 66 ans
de ce point de vue la question peut-être
faut-il s'inspirer de nos voisins ou
bien au contraire faut-il préserver
cette exception française ce qu'il faut
préserver en France c'est notre système
de répartition en fait nous avons eu
retraite de répartition tourne ce vaut
pas tout ne peut pas être comparé et à
ce titre là je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui est quand même globalement
assez partagé après pour pouvoir
préserver cette retraite à laquelle nous
sommes tous très attachés il nous faut
faire un certain nombre de réformes donc
le sujet de savoir est-ce que il faut
qu'on aille jusqu'à 64 ans 65 ans dans
d'autres pays beaucoup plus loin
ne se posent pas dans de bons termes si
on devait comparer simplement cet aspect
là des choses parce que au sein même de
notre retraite de répartition il
subsiste encore un certain nombre
d'inégalités et je pense ce n'est pas
parfait la réforme n'est pas parfaite je
ne vais pas vous tenir ce discours là
mais ça va quand même dans le bon sens
d'ailleurs nous ici au Sénat
régulièrement tous les ans à l'occasion
du PLFSS c'était des propositions que
nous essayons de faire entendre par
l'exécutif alors sans le soutien des dép
galère le texte a peu de chance de
passer et sans le soutien également au
Sénat à part si un 49-3 est utilisé il a
fallu donc négocier pour la première
ministre les LR ont obtenu le fait que
ceux ayant commencé à travailler entre
20 et 21 ans pourront finalement partir
donc à 63 ans et non plus 604 autre
problématique lié à la réforme le
travail des seniors selon une étude
réalisée en 2021 56% des 55-74 ans avait
un emploi au moment de partir donc à cet
âge le gouvernement souhaite-lui créer
via cette réforme des retraites un index
senior pour mieux connaître la place des
salariés en fin de carrière et ainsi
valoriser les bonnes pratiques et
dénoncer les mauvaises est-ce que c'est
index senior c'est une bonne chose selon
vous alors écoutez on va voir finalement
de sous quelle forme le texte va nous
arriver ici définitivement en revanche
il y a quelque chose qui est évidemment
soulevé à travers votre question et à
travers les quelques mesures évoquées
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui en
France un vrai sujet sur l'emploi des
seniors et sur l'emploi des jeunes et
lorsque vous faites ce qui part en
gonage et c'est ça mériterait d'ailleurs
que ce soit véritablement fait y compris
dans le débat public on observe que dans
les pays où vous avez un beau taux
d'employabilité des seniors vous avez un
très beau taux d'employabilité de la
jeunesse ça veut dire que les deux
éléments les deux phénomènes ne sont pas
du tout contradictoires donc déjà cela
il ne faut pas l'opposer mais je
voudrais aussi soulever ce qui manque
également dans ce texte là et qui moi
m'interpelle malgré tout c'est
la différence qui peut exister entre le
privé et le public je pense que là aussi
il y a pour beaucoup de Français une
véritable inégalité sur le calcul des
derniers semestres sur le calcul la
retraite donc je crois toujours pour
répondre pleinement à votre question que
la réforme des retraites là aujourd'hui
telle qu'elle est présentée est un texte
qui va en partie dans le bon sens donc
moi j'observe je vais regarder
véritablement qu'elle sera le texte que
nous aurons à examiner ici au Sénat mais
ne perdons pas de vue que le texte ne
sera de toute façon pas complet ne
répondra pas à toutes les questions que
les Français sont en droit de se poser
alors au sein de votre famille politique
une voix celle de David Lisnard défend
un autre système de retraite celui par
capitalisation dans lequel le salarié
autofinance s'appropre retraite alors
aujourd'hui notre système c'est la
répartition vous l'avez dit vous
souhaitez le défendre dans le donc dans
ce système les actifs cotisent pour
financer donc la retraite des inactifs
le maire de Cannes lui propose qu'un
étage de capitalisation sur un socle de
répartition soit appliquée est-ce que
cette idée pourrait vous convaincre vous
qui disiez juste à 20 ans à l'instant
qu'il faille défendre le système par
répartition ce que j'ai dit précisément
c'est que nous avons un système de
répartition qui est fort et qui est très
ancré en France qu'il ne faut pas
fragiliser ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que je ne suis pas pour un
système aussi partiellement de ça se
pratique aujourd'hui en France il existe
sur un certain nombre il y a des
dispositifs qui vont dans ce sens là
donc ne les balayons pas ils peuvent
peut être aussi une partie de la
solution pour permettre à un français
qui a envie de cotiser en partie pour sa
propre retraite qui puisse le faire donc
je pense que ce n'est pas il ne faut pas
opposer les deux en revanche il faut
trouver le bon équilibre pour
véritablement chacun il trouve son
compte donc oui c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut de toute façon examiner et
regarder de près alors on l'a vu à
l'Assemblée nationale tous les députés
LR ne votent pas ensemble il y a parfois
des distorsions sur la ligne politique à
avoir Éric Ciotti le nouveau président
du parti a parfois du mal à jouer les
équilibristes entre les différentes
entre les différentes volontés
d'opposition entre une opposition ferme
et une opposition constructive qui
pourrait faire penser à une forme
d'alliance avec la macronie alors
aujourd'hui quelle place doit occuper LR
selon vous
alors moi je suis
parce que lorsque l'on regarde en
réalité dans les territoires nous avons
encore
un certain nombre de messages à faire
passer et qui sont en réalité
soutenus en fait par un beaucoup de
notre population la grande force du
parti aujourd'hui c'est son ancrage
local encore aujourd'hui nous sommes en
véritable difficulté enfin je veux dire
il faut pas se cacher derrière son son
petit dames mais ça ne veut pas dire
pour autant que nos idées sont mortes en
tant que tel et n'existe pas donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut que nous
ayons quand même en tête et moi je le
fais partie de celles et de ceux qui
pensent que nous avons encore tout à
reconstruire en partant sur nos idées
sur les valeurs puis sont celles portées
par la famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens et je suis je reste
persuadé que nous avons encore beaucoup
de choses à partager et à dire et à
porter dans le débat public donc ne nous
trompons pas ne pas juger je dirais
l'ensemble de ce que peut être notre
famille politique à travers un pas sur
un texte de loi simplement c'est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça et ça va
nécessiter de à chacun d'entre nous de
faire sa part de du travail du job si je
peux l'exprimer ainsi alors le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale ce sont mis
d'accord sur la loi relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable pour participer
donc aux objectifs du pacte vert
européen qui veut faire de notre
continent un continent neutre en carbone
à l'horizon 2050 un projet de loi avec 4
piliers donc d'abord accélérer les
procédures ensuite libérer le foncier
nécessaire accélérer également le
déploiement de l'éolien en mer et enfin
améliorer le financement et
l'attractivité des projets d'énergie
renouvelables alors quels sont les
modifications que vous que vous aviez
souhaité apporter à ce projet de loi au
Sénat alors déjà moi j'avais déposé un
amendement qui avait été voté ici qui
était en réalité vous savez que je suis
sur les sujets d'économie circulaire et
environnementaux j'ai souhaité que l'on
tient compte de la fin de vie de ce que
sont les éoliennes que elle deviendrait
après puisque aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas véritablement de filières en réalité
suffisamment forte donc
mon amendement avait été voté au Sénat
il a été réécrit différemment donc et la
mesure est a été préservée dans le texte
définitif et à ce titre là je m'en
réjouis mais il y a d'autres apports du
Sénat je pense notamment à au fait que
les élus vont être concertés on ne
pourra pas implanter de l'éolien qu'on
soit pauvre qu'on soit contre moi
j'entends tous les avis sans pour autant
que les élus d'un territoire donné ne
donnent leur avis ça c'est quelque chose
qui est véritablement un apport du Sénat
qui est important un droit de veto
ça a été traduit comme un droit de veto
c'est un terme que nous récusons ici en
fait parce que tout simplement lorsque
vous êtes un élu local et que vous avez
la gestion d'un territoire la moindre
des choses c'est que vous puissiez
donner votre avis vous ne bloquez pas
mais vous donnez votre avis et donc vous
peser dans le global deuxième apport qui
est ce pas les seuls mais deuxième chose
qui était très importante dans ce que
nous avons apporté dans le débat c'est
que vous savez que en termes de
production en termes de comment pourrais
de retomber financière les territoires
on était exclus c'est à dire que vous
pouviez avoir des retombées financières
mais qui n'allaient pas au bénéfice des
territoires là où était implantés
l'éolien mais aller dans des budgets
autres et le Sénat a permis justement
d'ailleurs c'est une façon dans une
certaine mesure d'envoyer un message
positif pour dire aux élus qui
souhaitent s'engager dans de
l'implantation d'éolien sur leur
territoire que ils ne seront pas les
grands-pères dans je dis ça entre
guillemets à un moment donné parce
qu'ils ne vont pas avoir juste à gérer
éventuellement les mécontents de leur
territoire mais il va y avoir aussi des
retombées qui leur permettront ensuite
d'investir dans les projets du
territoire donc tout ça pour dire que le
débat a été dense le débat n'a pas été
toujours simple mais il me que nous
sommes arrivés à un texte de consensus
qui n'est pas inintéressant et qui nous
permet tous d'y trouver son compte en
fait parce que si je me souviens bien
lors de la campagne de l'élection
présidentielle Valérie Pécresse n'était
pas et les LR ou n'étiez pas extrêmement
favorable au développement de l'éolien
en mer qu'est-ce qui est aujourd'hui
vous vous fait changer d'avis et tous
moi personnellement je n'ai jamais été
opposé
à le précaution à avoir c'est que
l'éolien contrairement à ce que par le
passé on n'est plus du tout dans ce
discours là heureusement n'est pas une
énergie aussi propre qui peut sembler
puisque vous savez que maintenant on
tient compte du cycle de vie en fait de
toutes les mesures quelles qu'elles
soient et on observe que l'éolien n'est
pas si notre que cela d'un point de vue
environnemental et par ailleurs n'est
pas une énergie à production constante
il peut y avoir des moments de d'autres
énergies qui se substituent etc donc non
non le débat était relativement enfin
les esprits ont beaucoup évolué le débat
sur cet aspect là a aussi évolué mais
évidemment il y a toujours vous
trouverez de toujours tout bord
d'ailleurs des des élus locaux qui ne
souhaiteront pas avoir certainement
d'éoliennes dans sur leur territoire
donc il faut les accompagner sur la
politique locale le Sénat pour vocation
de représenter les collectivités
territoriales en matière de transition
écologique on a tendance à penser que
plus l'é des grandes plus on est
efficace mais les villes les communautés
d'agglomération les départements aussi
ont un rôle majeur à jouer dans la
transition écologique vous le vous le
pensez également oui moi je crois que
il ne faut pas opposer les aujourd'hui
nous avons des configurations qui sont
ceux qu'elles sont
voilà donc ne nous opposons pas c'est
déjà très compliqué aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une période de finance
contrainte donc je pense que au-delà de
se dire est-ce qu'on est ce qu'il y a
trop d'échelons pas et je vais enfin bon
bref tous ces débats que l'on traîne je
le dis vraiment comme ça depuis des
années
administratifs
qui sont qu'on a abandonnés
chaque jour j'ai envie de dire on a de
nouvelles réflexions qui arrivent je
crois que la vraie la vraie question que
l'on doit tous se poser sur ton en cette
période c'est quelle est l'efficacité en
fait de ce que nous faisons les uns et
les autres et travaillons plus j'ai
envie de dire avec une plus forte
proximité les uns avec les autres une
chose est certaine et cette période de
crise nous la véritablement enseigné et
démontré si encore en doutait
parce que l'échelon communal est
fondamental on a vu avec la crise avec
la pandémie les Français ce sont tous
tournés vers leurs élus locaux et vers
leur mère pour qui avait telle
difficulté
les masques les mises en place de tout
ce qui était vaccinodrome on a oublié
tout cela mais en réalité ce sont les
communes qui ont organisé finalement
véritablement cette gestion de proximité
ne l'oublions pas donc moi je crois que
aujourd'hui ne nous opposons pas c'est
pas le moment c'est des sujets qui
véritablement et certainement nous
occupons à l'avenir mais dans le
contexte actuel moi je crois qu'il ne
faut pas qu'on oublie que la proximité
l'efficacité et le dialogue entre les
différents échelons et fondamentales on
parlait de politique énergétique à
l'instant la politique énergétique de la
France n'est pas seulement les énergies
neuronouvelables mais c'est aussi la
poursuite du nucléaire dans un contexte
où l'indépendance énergétique devient un
enjeu politique la France souhaite
accélérer aussi sur donc le nu en
accélérant les procédures pour
construire ces nouveaux fameux nouveaux
réacteurs simplification des procédures
est-ce que ça veut dire moins de
sécurité bien sûr que non bien sûr que
non et j'ai envie dire enfin enfin on
s'est posé la bonne question et on y
apporte une réponse je crois que
aujourd'hui ce dont il faut se souvenir
c'est que la France a avait je parle au
passé et j'en suis vraiment désolé une
production
décarbonée en quantité dont on s'est
privé pour un tas de raisons idéologique
et aujourd'hui en fin de redécouvrir les
le bénéfice du nucléaire moi tout à
l'heure vous avez entendu comme moi en
hémicycle madame panier rue hachée qui
avait l'air de redécouvrir le bénéfice
des carbonés de cette énergie nucléaire
personnellement je crois que c'est une
très bonne chose et pour répondre
vraiment à votre sujet de sécurité sur
bien évidemment comme n'importe quel
process industriel il y a des
précautions à prendre
la France a toujours été pilote en fait
en matière énergétique nucléaire et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui ce à quoi nous
devons être vigilants ce sont les
formations dans ces filières là parce
que à force d'annoncer par le passé que
nous allions fermer tous nos réacteurs
vous avez beaucoup de talons qui se sont
détournés de la filière nucléaire pour
faire autre chose donc c'est ça qu'il va
falloir reconstruire et rebâtir mais ça
ne veut pas dire pour autant que la
sécurité de nos centrales nucléaires est
menacées
[Musique]
toujours avec Martha de Sidrac sénatrice
air des Yvelines le Sénat a aussi adopté
la loi anti-squat une nouvelle loi
attendue suite à la méditation de
nombreuses affaires la nouvelle loi
triple désormais les sanctions contre
les squatteurs qui risqueront maintenant
45000 euros d'amende et 3 ans
d'emprisonnement si la loi est adoptée
en dernière lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale un texte que la majorité juge
équilibrée puisque vous avez conservé au
Sénat donc la possibilité de pénaliser
le locataire qui se maintient dans les
lieux à la suite d'un jugement
d'expulsion alors est-ce que cette
nouvelle loi à vocation à réduire le
nombre de situations qu'on a vu
récemment
plusieurs fois dans les médias
l'espère en réalité je crois que nous
nous trompons pas
là
d'ailleurs elle porte bien son nom c'est
une loi anti-squatte c'est-à-dire une
occupation illégale d'un bien qui ne
vous appartient pas on n'est pas du tout
dans le discours comme certains
voulaient le faire croire que on était
dans de
dans
confronté à des locataires qui avaient
des difficultés de paiement de loyer
comme ça peut arriver etc ce sont deux
sujets très différents et les
dispositions et les mesures qui ont été
votées dans cette dans ce cadre-là on
repréciser les choses et je crois que de
ce point de vue c'est bien c'est c'est
bien comment comment moi je le vois dans
mon territoire expliquer un propriétaire
qui rentre dans les placement que
subitement il y a quelqu'un dans son
logement qui a changé les serrures et il
mettra des parce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui des mois voire des années à
pouvoir récupérer son bien mais non
seulement ça c'est à dire que aussi si
l'arrivée quoi que ce soit au sein de ce
logement
occupé illégalement il en était toujours
responsable donc je pense qu'il y avait
aussi une équité à remettre au coeur de
ce débat c'est ce que nous avons fait
donc nous verrons quel sera
définitivement le texte adopté mais en
tout cas je trouve que c'est un texte
oui équilibré et qui répond à un certain
nombre de questionnements de français
propriétaire quand on dit propriétaire
on s'imagine des propriétaires de
Château de telles particules c'est pas
du tout ça c'est on la véritablement on
s'adresse à à des Français qui ont
économisé toute leur vie pour pouvoir
acheter un bien et qui un jour se
retrouve avec un bien qu'il aura été
confisqué de façon illégale poursuivons
maintenant sur la thématique du logement
avec le la problématique du sans-abrisme
20 maires de gauche de grandes villes
ont publié une lettre ouverte dans le
JDD adressée à Emmanuel Macron sur ce
sujet parmi eux Anne Hidalgo maire de
Paris ou encore Grégory Doucet maire de
Lyon il réclame une loi de programmation
et de planification des places
d'hébergement alors que la Fondation
Abbé Pierre affirme qu'il y a en France
330 000 personnes en situation de de
sans-abrisme selon une étude c'est
l'équivalent de la ville de Nantes pour
donner un ordre d'idée c'est un constat
d'échec un peu pour les politiques
menées précédemment est-ce qu'on peut
résoudre ce problème où il y a une
certaine fatalité je pense qu'il faut
s'y atteler et d'ailleurs quand je dis
il faut s'y atteler
on s'en certain nombre de dispositifs
qui existent en termes de d'hébergement
d'urgence insuffisant mais la vraie
question en fait qui se cache derrière
cela c'est comment expliquer vous que
dans un pays comme la France aujourd'hui
on se retrouve avec de tels chiffres
c'est quand même quelque chose qui doit
nous interpeller et comment expliquer
aussi qu'aujourd'hui lorsque vous
rentrez dans du logement social Vous
n'en sortez quasiment pas de votre vie
parce que vous n'en avez pas les moyens
il y a un tel pas à franchir pour
pouvoir passer du du logement social à
du logement privé que ça doit nous
interroger sur la manière même dont
d'une part
cet écart de loyer qui peut exister la
manière même dont on fait
nos emplois nous permettent nos salaires
nous permettent de nos loger ça il y a
une vraie question qui reviendra je
pense à travers différents textes et je
prends moi l'exemple des Yvelines dans
les nous avons des associations qui
travaillent sur le terrain au quotidien
moi-même par le passé je faisais des
maraudes de nuit pour constater cela et
nous avons de l'ordre de 3000
hébergements d'urgence possible dans
notre département qui qui parfois aussi
sont refusés par les personnes que l'on
va et que l'on essaye d'assister donc je
pense qu'il y a une vraie une vraie
interrogation à avoir aussi sur ce que
seront en fait ces lieux d'hébergement
d'urgence pourquoi autant de sans-abris
et pourquoi vous l'avez vous même relevé
leur chiffre augmente on a une espèce de
paupérisation à cause d'un pouvoir
d'achat en berne voire qui baisse donc
il est vrai que c'est une question à
laquelle nous n'avons pas encore de
réponse satisfaisantes mais à laquelle
bien évidemment il est évident qu'il va
falloir se pencher et je ne veux je ne
suis pas sûr de l'information mais il me
semble que il va y avoir des PPL qui
vont proposer dans ce sens là donc on
aura l'occasion d'en reparler ici au
Parlement j'aimerais revenir maintenant
un Marta de cidrac sur ce vote qui a été
extrêmement médiatisé sur l'inscription
du droit à l'avortement dans la
Constitution 166 votes pour et 150 de
vote contre un choix qui a divisé votre
groupe politique 16 sénateurs LR on vote
pour vous vous avez voté contre pourquoi
ce vote alors d'une part parce que moi
je pense qu'en politique il faut être
toujours cohérent avec ses votes lorsque
nous l'avions examiné fin d'année
dernière j'étais déjà sur la même
position pour une raison toute simple
aujourd'hui en France dans l'état actuel
du texte enfin de la loi l'IVG n'est pas
menacé vous vous je rappelle simplement
rapidement les raisons pour lesquelles
le texte a été déposé c'est que il y a
eu évidemment ce que l'on a vu aux
États-Unis et donc certains ont craint
que en France également ce droit à l'IVG
soit menacé ce n'est pas le cas ce n'est
pas le cas et moi je je défie quiconque
de trouver un parti politique
aujourd'hui en France qui aurait déclaré
être contre l'IVG et vouloir revenir sur
les lois déjà votées pour lesquelles
d'ailleurs la droite est le centre ont
porté véritablement l'argument qui
revient dans ce cas et on l'a vu la
semaine dernière avec le sénateur Rémi
Féraud il disait que c'était parce que
les États-Unis ils se référer à la
situation politique aux États-Unis
configuration parlementaire et
démocratique en tant que tel les
États-Unis sont un grand pays
démocratique nous le sommes également
mais nous n'avons pas exactement les
mêmes institutions elles ne fonctionnent
pas exactement de la même manière moi
j'attire votre attention par rapport au
texte qui a été voté pourquoi j'ai voté
contre l'amendement en fait parce que
c'est ça c'est à dire que au Sénat nous
avons voté un texte modifié par un
amendement qui a été déposé par un de
nos collègues et la raison pour laquelle
d'une part constance comme je le disais
tout à l'heure mais aussi parce que ce
quand vous regardez l'article 34
aujourd'hui dans l'article 34 en réalité
qui se réfère aux droits fondamentaux
des Français il y était il y avait un
consensus national en France pour dire
que l'IVG faisait partie de ses droits
en fait des Français le fait de
constitutionnaliser à travers
l'amendement qui a été voté en disant
que cela devient que la loi finalement
définit la liberté en matière d'IVG en
réalité ma conviction intime c'est que
nous fragilisons ce droit là moi je suis
pour l'IVG je pense que c'est quelque
chose qui a été obtenu pour les femmes
de longue lutte et je crois qu'il faut
qu'on fasse attention à ne pas
fragiliser et à ne pas lancer des débats
qui iraient en réalité à contre emploi
aujourd'hui en France on n'a pas de
sujet là dessus alors on a un autre
argument qui nous est parfois à renvoyer
à la figure en disant il y a des
territoires où les femmes ne peuvent pas
faire diriger mais ce n'est pas parce
que on ne alors répondre à leur demande
simplement parce que là c'est un autre
sujet crucial éminemment important en ce
moment c'est que nous sommes aujourd'hui
en France confrontés au désert médicaux
et de la même manière vous seriez
cardiaque vous n'aurez peut-être pas à
votre cardiologue à côté de chez vous
malheureusement parfois il arrive aussi
que des femmes dépassent les Lego parce
que en fait vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de de on n'a pas la
possibilité de répondre à votre demande
dans les délais dans votre lieu
géographique
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous êtes
sénatrice LR des Yvelines et nous on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de l'hebdopolitique sur
Radio sensation très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]